what is going on everybody ale welcome
to a another part of the Python plays
Grand Theft Auto series in this video
what I'm gonna be doing is attempting to
put tensor flows object detection API on
to this machine so currently I am I just
upgraded tensorflow
so we should be on import tensor tensor
flow as TF and the conversion should be
one point one one release candidate zero
now I'm a little concerned that this may
or may not work very well because the
object detection API historically has
been quite finicky especially when it
comes to the you know Pro taki all that
stuff so and I think tensorflow won
after like 1.9 or something like that
requires a specific version protobuf and
then you're going to need a specific
version to work with object detection so
that'll be fun
alright so let's go ahead and get
started I'm gonna be using a few things
first of all python program net the the
object detection api tutorial i did
should prove to be somewhat useful in
this endeavor and then also if you just
google
let's do tensorflow object detection AP
i look for videos this one right here
from edge electronics hey idiots I'm
gonna hop to the github here and we are
going to make use of a few of the
commands here as I went through so I
looked to see if I could find any more
recent than my tutorial on doing tensor
flows object detection API and I found
this one and at least this one is
updated to tensorflow 1.7
and then the pythonpath stuff apparently
is not even required anyway the video is
for 1.5 and I noticed there are a few
different commands also the pro TOC
command has changed pretty significantly
so I'm pretty sure those two things are
gonna be a problem plus in the comment
section I was seeing people were saying
like this is the wild card doesn't work
anymore which is what a weird thing to
change this like that it's like sloshing
around hopefully y'all didn't hear that
but you probably did okay so so that's
what we're gonna be working on so first
of all well the private more important
thing is tensorflow object detection API
let's go to the official Docs here maybe
I'll scroll well I can see this really
well it's just this is probably pretty
small for you guys but anyway uh
scrolling on down to installation
alright because you don't just need this
instant this is the truth from the very
very beginning it's like you you need
more than this installation to get this
thing working for real like I wish you
could get the full installation of the
tensorflow object the section API using
their install suggestions but you can't
okay so we've already got tensor flow
GPU have already well I haven't shown
you but TF version we may end up needing
to change this it's it's a requirement
for me that we are able to run tensor
flow object detection so so I may end up
downgrading this I really don't want to
write my own tensor flow object
detection API I mean there's a lot of
work going in and this is actually a
really great API but it could just be
tedious to use and setup but the first
thing that we're going to go ahead and
do is install you know all these little
requirements here so I'm just going to
also wonder if I can dang it let's see
properties fine let's go with a good old
24 okay let's quit out of here and we're
gonna do make sure pip is Python 3 6
it is alright so we need to install all
of these so scythe on context live and
all that so I'm gonna run pip install I
think we should be able we should be
safe to upgrade all of these so scythe
on conte no comma man context lib to
pillow LX ml Jupiter Jupiter and
matplotlib okay so this is like there
let's see I think they they do
differentiate usually between Windows
and Linux or I thought they did I don't
see it here cool thanks guys but one of
the other things we need is that
protobuf stuff so next thing I'm gonna
do is bebop on over oh maybe it was me
that differentiated between Windows
anyway yeah they don't even bother
telling you like hey by the way on
Windows you're gonna have to take some
extra steps ok so um so we're gonna head
over to the pro talk release page
Chara's but you'll have Karis emulation
compatible with the show must go on sirs
wait we didn't upgrade hopefully that
doesn't break wait wait hold on let me
go back yeah uh where is the okay well
we'll deal with that in a minute so
first of all it suggests that I think we
can get away with 3 plus pro talk from
what I could see in the comment section
people were just saying that you can't
use the wild card which isn't a big deal
so I'm going to because this lovely
lovely person edge electronics I think
it was somewhere in section 2 somewhere
somewhere yeah it's like a really like
rather than using the wild card he just
wrote out all all of them so good work
soldier
we're gonna make use of that so I'm
gonna try to get away with three six I
don't even know let's see if this guy
mentions oh my gosh this scroll wheel on
here needs to go faster let me just do a
pro talk so should be before the compile
Pro talks when did he Frodo portable
files have not been compiled
oh he uses Conda to install protobuf I
don't think we can do that pip install
proto of Pro Talk yeah if somebody knows
how we can use protobuf I would love to
know like just by like a pip install but
I don't think that's ever gonna work out
for you unless maybe we do the pathing
stuff but I don't think that's gonna
work anyway so we've got the installs
that's basically the first thing that we
want to do next thing we want to do is
go ahead and clone this stuff so I'm
going to nope not this one I want to
clone oh well while we're here let's
grab Pro talk we might have to downgrade
pro talk but for now I'm just gonna grab
it here Potok three six one we might
need to go with like a three point four
or even a 3.0 the docs specifically say
3.0 but I know three point four works
because my latest tutorial did three
point four so um stuff this I think I'm
gonna throw it in C though to be honest
and where'd it go here it is so I'm
going to actually later let's create a
new directory I'm gonna call it pro tunc
this may or may not be a great idea but
I'm gonna do it anyways and extract all
cool so now pro-gross why did it do that
that's not what I wanted
hold on let's open a new window cut it
pastes and I'm just gonna remove these
ok so now when we want a reference pro
talk we just specify the path C colon
slash Pro talk easy enough so now what
we want to do is clone this entire like
models directory from tensorflow
so I'm just gonna click on this main
here so models and then it has like
slash research and stuff which was kind
of a hardship for people to overcome at
some point they like added the research
directory I guess for organizations sake
so I'll go ahead and download the models
folder the short makes them some great
noises and I think I think I'm just
going to throw it to the desktop for now
trying to decide if that's really where
I want it I guess I'll leave it in the
desktop so anyways it's on the desktop
extract all oh my gosh please no is it
really gonna take five minutes to
extract this Oh gross man dang it oh we
should have been doing this while we
were doing other stuff thank you okay so
let's see what else could we do while we
wait on that okay I think it's gonna
speed up for us so I guess you know we
just need to wait so I guess I'll pause
now and then we can continue on when
this is when this is done although you
guys are all gonna have to sit through
it anyway so
maybe you guys can extract faster than
me this feels like it's like super super
slow so once we have this all extracted
the next thing we're going to do is use
the protocol buffer to compile all these
things so going over to an edge
electronics I'll try to remember to put
a link in the description but if I
forget which I probably might just
Google tentative object detection API
you should find this you should
recognize this photo this is car on his
head anyway and then you should find
your way to this github at least that's
what I'm using for now we'll see if this
works
and I'm sure we'll have to change some
stuff although it looks like maybe he's
been updating it over time which is nice
so let's see models where did it go here
ooh
it's hard to see that on this desktop
okay so models master and then this is
it so the first thing we'll do is we are
gonna rename this just to models it's
kind of silly to be models master and
then this I guess I'll leave that for
some reason this extracts differently
than I think my home computer does like
normally if I extracted models master it
would extract just the contents and not
start with this original directory
anyway so the next thing we want to do
is go down to I think for him it was
like step to F right and I think the
next thing we want to do here is run
these this pro TOC command again I'm not
really sure I guess he could do it
because of anaconda so if you have
anaconda you could just do the Conda
install protobuf but this whole thing
needs to be run so the first thing we're
going to do is just copy then I'm gonna
hit copy I'm gonna open up like a
notepad or something because this needs
to not be pro talk it needs to be C
colon slash pro talk
that should work and then Python out and
then all of these things and he's
running this from object that XO object
detection needs to be so research and
then he's running object detection so
right so hopefully from here we should
be able get away with this
so let's open up a command prompt really
pretty sure oh do I need to let's put
some quotes around this maybe oh you
know what I'm doing wrong so it should
be pro talk and then it's probably bin
and then pro talk so C colon slash pro
talk bin Pro top pro tunc copy okay so
we got all those great now the next
thing I'm actually not sure I don't
think in the past that was required the
build and install I don't think it is
because we're running from the directory
maybe if we wanted to use it outside of
the models let's let's find out so
research let's go down to object
detection hello hello there we are and
we should be no I did not click that
stop it
let's see what else he's doing here I
think cuz he's also doing like the
creation of your automatic like creating
your own object detection I don't think
we're gonna need to do that I just want
to at least here get to the point of
running the the actual thing let's see
okay so we got the Jupiter notebook here
so if I do this
Jupiter notebook let's see if this thing
pops up well or not cool okay so then
we're going to open up the object
detection tutorial and here is where we
probably fail this will be the first
failure point
yes invalid version number come on guys
come on do why do we got to do this
let's see ok ok ok here
I don't even read those lines so it
really wants us to use 1.9 really let's
try again so it sounds like we probably
made it to that point whoa we did
sometimes like in the actual code like
the source code they'll have one of
these like strict version checks and
that's super annoying son you gotta find
it I don't even realize it's right there
cool ok matplotlib in line that's fine
whatever ok this will be the next
failure point no oh wait hold on
everybody this um I think we're just
gonna continue along that looks really
ugly but uh price should just run all at
this point okay looks like we might make
it through what we might have this
that's some that was an ugly thing but I
what threw me off is right at the end it
just it's like more of like a warning
than anything else so hey whatever come
on
please work if this works I'm gonna be
so ecstatic this was not yes ah
wonderful
okay so I am going to stick with my
original estimate that the build and
install is only gonna be required if you
wanted to run this outside of that
models directory in the past I couldn't
figure out how to get that to work I
could only run it from within the whole
like models thing so I'm kind of curious
at this point to check that so I'm just
gonna check that but first a quick
shadow
- my mother's reason sponsors actually
members I keep calling sponsors YouTube
just really should never have released
it because now I'm gonna always call
them sponsors and never members and
hopefully eventually they'll give us a
way to customize the name anyways thank
you - Bonnie
Singh ball juanny I think I don't know
correct me Alan dole Allendale Valencia
mr. Jean jeans these names are killing
me I can't do it
yeah Andrew again correct me if I'm
wrong and art nice wick guy Andrew guy
Andrew shy Andrew not sure anyways thank
you guys very very much for your support
helps me continue doing stuff like this
and I love my job so thanks a lot and
okay so let me remember to remove these
and not leave them up and okay so what I
want to do now is attempt attempt to run
this outside of here so no yeah I've
changed my mind because I've got to move
in like grab screen I've got to move in
some other things so it might actually
be best for me to see installing the
object that you know with the set up top
I be like build and install stuff to see
if I can actually run that elsewhere so
I am actually gonna cut it here so I
will see you guys in the next video
where we run it in-game and see how
that's working and maybe try a few of
the different models and go with
whatever we think is best so that's it
for now I will see you guys in the next
video